un souvenir douloureux et surtout une
quête de justice trois ans plus tard la
mort de jamal khashoggi continue de
jeter une ombre sur le règne de mohamed
bin salman tenu pour responsable dans
l'assassinât du journaliste en février
dernier par un rapport des services de
renseignement américains le prince
saoudien n'a toujours pas reçu la
moindre sanction on sait que bin salman
a dirigé cet assassinat qui s'inscrit
dans une vaste opération visant à faire
taire les dissidents établis à
l'étranger il a malgré tout échappé à
tout responsabilisation d'une manière
qui semble suggérer que ce type de
comportement est approprié la fiancée de
jamal khashoggi n'a pas non plus mâché
ses mots lors de cette visioconférence
elle met directement la pression sur joe
biden on se souvient que durant sa
campagne présidentielle
le locataire de la maison blanche avait
pris le contre-pied de donald trump et
s'en était pris agressivement à l'arabie
saoudite
promettant de ramener le pays au rang de
paria en raison des exactions imputées
ariane mais depuis sa prise de pouvoir
ces mots sont devenus quelque peu
édulcorée en témoigne ce contrat
d'armement signé avec l'arabie saoudite
il y a deux semaines appelle le premier
sous l'ère maiden un contrat pouvant
atteindre 500 millions de dollars
destinés à assurer la maintenance de la
flotte saoudienne d'hélicoptères ce qui
intéresse les arrêts 1 en premier c'est
l'argent et c'est la vente de leur
équipement militaire et il devrait
normalement gêné par par ce parce prince
héritier qui commet des assassinats qui
fait des attentats et qui enclenche des
guerres un peu partout mais
malheureusement ils achètent énormément
d'armement aux américains est aussi bien
aux français et ils arrivent à s'en
passer les américains sont attachés
points et mains liées par les saoudiens
par l'argent des saoudiens et mbs
profitent de cet argent pour pouvoir
j'allais dire museler les américains le
prince héritier tire son épingle du jeu
grâce à la puissance financière de ryad
et cela va même plus loin lors du procès
de ce terrible meurtre qui a connu son
issue il y a un an la justice saoudienne
a condamné à des peines allant de 7 à 20
ans de prison
accusés jugés pour leur implication dans
la mort de jamal khashoggi un procès à
huit lots qui n'a pas respecté les
principes mêmes de la justice pour
reporters sans frontières qualifié de
honteux par les nations unies notamment
pour agnès callamard l'experte de l'onu
ayant enquêté sur cet assassinat pour
elle ces peines ne sont pas suffisantes
car elles ne prennent pas en compte la
question de la responsabilité de la
chaîne de commandement même son cloche
pour la compagne du journaliste saoudien
le jugement rendu aujourd'hui en arabie
saoudite se moque à nouveau complètement
de la justice les autorités saoudiennes
classe la faire sans que le monde sache
la vérité sur l'identité du responsable
du meurtre de jamal qu'il a planifié
qu'il a ordonnés où est son corps ce
sont les questions les plus
fondamentales et les plus importantes
qui reste totalement sans réponse
la communauté internationale n'acceptera
pas cette farce je suis plus déterminé
que jamais à me battre pour que justice
soit rendue à jamal à 110 n'a pas menti
par la suite elle a lancé une poursuite
civile aux états unis contre mohamed bin
salman et plusieurs membres de son
entourage en raison de leur rôle allégué
dans la mort de jamal khashoggi là
encore le prince héritier a réponse à
tout quand ce n'est pas l'argent ce sont
ses avocats qui cherche actuellement à
faire valoir que le tribunal n'a pas
compétence dans ce dossier un face à
face qui ressemble à un remake de david
et goliath mais contrairement au récit
biblique l'issue est plus qu'incertaine